j'ai une confidence à vous faire j'étais
techniques pour mieux dormir quand rien
ne va plus vous êtes vous déjà retrouvé
en pleine nuit les yeux grands ouverts à
voir défiler viseur du réveil sans
pouvoir dormir débranchez votre cerveau
à ressasser un problème à essayer de
trouver une solution
à combien d'entre vous est il arrivé de
mettre des heures à vous endormir à vous
retourner dans tous les sens lever la
main ce qui cogite la nuit lever la main
ceux qui ont déjà vécu des réveils
nocturnes lever la main ceux qui ont
rencontré des réveil précoce
vous savez quand on se réveille bien
avant l'heure du réveil bon bah y'en a
même qui ont le tiercé gagnant ne pas
bien dormir est un problème qui touche
62% des français et qui concerne 99 %
des personnes que j'accompagne ils
viennent me voir au cabinet de
sophrologie en première intention pour
gérer leurs douleurs leurs douleurs
chroniques colopathie fonctionnelle
migraine acouphènes quiberon maji mode
ventes de dow de tête
ils viennent aussi pour dépasser un
événement qui génère de l'anxiété par
exemple un cancer un changement de
situation
un deuil à licenciement une séparation
un burn-out
ils viennent aussi pour préparer des
événements spécifiques
alors le bac les concours universitaire
sportif un spectacle où une opération
chirurgicale ces événements peuvent
générer par retour des insomnies qui
peuvent provoquer à la longue et
aggraver leur état de santé
à ce stade il s'oriente vers deux
stratégies possibles pour mieux dormir
premières stratégies pour mieux dormir
ne rien faire est arrivé le jour j ai
puisé physiquement et nerveusement à
côté de leurs pompes deuxième stratégie
possible pour mieux dormir avalé un
somnifère qui donne l'illusion du
sommeil et dont les effets sédatifs
anesthésiant sur le cerveau se prolonge
au-delà de la nuit avec baisse de
vigilance père de mémoire de
concentration de créativité on n'est pas
très frais dix cerveaux canton l'année
saisi toute la nuit sans oublier la
diction ouais ouais
la plupart de deux d'entre eux avant de
venir me voir en ont pris pendant une
dizaine d'années sans pouvoir arrêter
car l'effet rebond à l'arrêt l'effet
rebond d'insomnie est extrêmement
angoissant vous ne dormez plus du tout
enfin votre cerveau ne sait plus dormir
naturellement quand omar la quarantaine
hyperactif arrive au cabinet il
m'explique qu'il se sent tout le temps
fatigué il est épuisé il ne dort plus
bien depuis des jours des semaines des
mois des années et il a vraiment tout
tout tout tout essayé en réalité
thomas ne sait plus comment faire moi
je lui propose de sortir du cadre avec
une troisième stratégie basée sur les
neurosciences en 2014
les résultats des études et nero
scientifiques suisses et américains ont
conclu les insomniaques ont un niveau de
cortisol plus élevé que la moyenne
de jour comme de nuit deuxième point le
cerveau insomniaques persiste pendant la
nuit à être dans un état qui perd
excitation l'insomnie est très souvent
une impossibilité à ralentir l'activité
électrique du cerveau a tourné le bouton
du volume
comment font les navigateurs de course
pour dormir sur commande
comment font les aéronautes les joueurs
d'échecs et même les joueurs de poker
pour récupérer rapidement
je vais vous offrir cette troisième
stratégie ce qui marche avec thomas bon
voilà comment ça se passe quand thomas
arrive au cabinet il n'arrive plus à
lâcher prise
la nuit venue impossible de passer par
le corps avec la relaxation tellement il
est bloqué impossible de calmer le
mental avec la méditation
il n'en a plus la patience il est
astucieux de commencer par reprendre son
souffle de moduler son souffle et de
passer en cohérence cardiaque alors la
cohérence cardiaque
c'est un rythme particulier de la
respiration où l'on expire sur cinq
secondes et où on inspire sur cinq
secondes
ce rythme sera valable pour chacun
d'entre vous il correspond à 6
respirations par minute en journée quand
nous sommes au calme nous sommes entre
12 nous faisons douze à quinze
respirations par minute quand nous
parlons nous montons au dessus de 20 et
quand nous dormons nous descendons en
dessous de 10 ce rythme particulier va
entrer en résonance avec notre système
nerveux autonome
celui qui calme ou accélère votre
cerveau
c'est une cohérence physiologique corps
cerveau alors cette technique à la plein
d'atouts dont deux particulièrement qui
nous intéresse pour bien dormir
ben elle fait descendre le taux de
cortisol en trois minutes mesures à
l'appui et ses effets se prolongent
pendant quatre à six heures elle
augmente la production des ondes
cérébrales alpha c'est l'état où le
cerveau est en mode veille attentive et
calme on vit alors un état descoings
imiter c'est à dire une pause de calme
émotionnel notre cerveau a débranché des
soucis et nous sommes recentrés
une fois que l'on a tourné le bouton du
volume est débranché libéral citation du
cerveau le plus important c'est de ne
pas laisser repartir le cerveau au galop
pendant la nuit alors j'installe
l'ingrédient essentiel une image
ressources par une technique de
visualisation ou le cerveau est invité à
se focaliser sur l'image sur certain
sens par exemple la couleur
cela permet aux autres centres d'éveil
du cerveau de stan progressivement et de
réguler nos neurotransmetteur ce nos
messagers chimiques
c'est maintenant une cohérence cerveau
corps une étude publiée dans le new
scientist révèle que les insomniaques
qui s'endorment avec des pensées
contenant des images apaisantes nous
cassent cadeau un paysage ensoleillé
s'endorment de 20 minutes plus
rapidement qu'il ne le faisait
habituellement
alors cette image va ralentir la
dispersion mentale et favoriser
l'installation d'un sentiment de
sécurité d'abaissement ingrédients
indispensables pour une nuit paisible
bon si j'étais là assis à écouter ce
tedx je crois que j'aimerais bien vivre
la technique et je sais aussi que les
bonnes résolutions sont souvent remises
à plus tard alors ben comme je suis là
pour vous osons et entrons dans cette
technique
d'abord la posture installez-vous fond
de votre fauteuil
le dos bien droit décroisé vos jambes
des pieds bien à plat
allez-y pour réactiver la respiration
ventrale dont nous allons avoir besoin
nous allons à 3 et tous ensemble faire
un
vous êtes prêts 1 2 3 se sentent et
ensuite levante qui se regonflent vous
respirer par le ventre
écoutez les notes qui descendent
et noter celle qui monte
oh
placez votre souffle maintenant
inspiré par le nez
oh
et à nouveau souffler par la bouche
on
shakespeare continuer les yeux fermés
j'inspire
c'est par la bouche on
inscrits par le nez
oh
on
garder les yeux fermés
et imaginez une image agréable positive
un joli souvenir de vacances
un bon moment de détente une photo une
carte postale un poster qui vous fait
rêver
la voyez vous
installer la visualisation projeter
votre image derrière vos paupières
fermées comme sur un écran de cinéma est
entré dans le film vous y êtes
découvrez votre environnement dans ce
film le paysage les lumières les
couleurs laisser venir
santé la douce chaleur sur votre peau ou
la fraîcheur d'un souffle d'air sur
votre visage laisser glisser le souffle
de la descente sur vous en vous profitez
profiter de ce bon moment
intégrer toutes les sensations les
perceptions les sentiment de bien-être
que cela génère en vous chez vous vous
pouvez continuer la visualisation sur
plusieurs minutes
nous nous allons faire le chemin du
retour ensemble maintenant
inspiré par le nez
et ouvrez les yeux waouh ça calme
c'est agréable n'est ce pas vous étiez
beau
ce que je vais vous dire c'est
n'attendez pas d'être dans la tempête de
l'insomnie pour débuter cet exercice
fait en une habitude tous les jours un
tout petit peu même quand vous n'avez
pas besoin et cela dès mars désamorcera
probablement certaines insomnies
entraînez-vous tous les jours que ça
devienne de plus en plus facile
automatique essayé sur une chaise dans
l'ascenseur sur un banc au cinéma
au bureau les portes fermées et pourquoi
pas ancien ce2 neuronale pendant cinq
minutes après les déjeuners et si
l'insomnie se pointe osé faire cette
pratique active et la doma la semaine
dernière est venu à sa séance de
sophrologie et il m'a raconté qu'il a
vécu une grosse mais grosse grosse
contrariété professionnel et qu'il
sentait que l'insomnie allait se
manifester
alors il a utilisé la respiration puis
la visualisation et s'est endormie
dessus
thomas a passé une bonne nuit bon je
voudrais vous demander de partager cette
pratique donné la donné là ceux qui se
plaignent de leur sommeil car ce sont
eux qui ont le plus besoin
donnez là en quelques instants
ils peuvent modifier sensiblement la
qualité de leur sommeil et donc leur
santé et la qualité de leur vie sur ce
je vous souhaite non pas une bonne nuit
mais une bonne soirée